Okay, I started.
Everybody started?
Are we all here?
Hello!
Hello everybody!
Hello everyone!
Hello!
Dero was sleeping!
Dero was sleeping.
That's you.
No!
I was sleeping.
I was just...
Yeah?
What were you?
You were just late?
Well, why were you late?
Yeah.
Why were you late?
I took a nap.
Just a nap.
Must leave.
She missed her alarm, guys.
She missed her alarm.
She slept through her alarm.
But I came here, okay?
We're all here!
I did wake up.
We're all here now.
Hey, why don't we all introduce ourselves?
Who wants to start?
Does anyone want to start?
I'll start?
Okay, hello!
I am Doki Bird.
Hello.
Okay, I'm done.
Thank you.
I accidentally sent my tomato picture to Hiro and Nachan.
And they were like, is this Doki?
And I was like, yeah.
Tomato!
Alright, who wants to go next?
I'm stupid tomato.
Who wants to go next?
Okay.
I can go next.
Hi, I'm Hiro.
Hiro, Hiro, Hiro.
Yeah.
That's it?
Nice to meet you.
Yeah, of course.
Thank you.
Alright.
Who's next?
Yeah, I'm excited.
I'm gonna capture ghosts.
Oh, wait, wait.
No.
Nachan should be last.
I won't ask Nachan a question after.
Ditto, you go next.
Okay.
Hi, I'm Ditto from Linkage 8.
Yay!
Nice to meet you.
Yeah.
Okay.
Nachan.
And...
She brought out the paper.
Hello everyone.
My name is Nachan.
I'm going to speak English.
I'm going to speak English fluently.
But I will try my best and let's have fun today.
Yay!
Nachan.
Can you...
What English words do you know, Nachan?
What English words?
Can you show us all your English?
Native English.
Yeah, native English.
Okay, okay.
Um...
What the what?
Nachan, did Hiro teach you this?
Hiro teach you, right?
No, no.
Right?
Right, Nachan?
Where did Nachan go?
Nachan, who teach Hiro?
Did Hiro teach?
YouTube.
Oh, YouTube.
Nachan, Nachan.
What did...
What did I teach you?
Teach me, teach me.
I taught you a word.
What did I teach you?
What the hell?
What does that mean, Nachan?
Amazing.
Yeah!
What the hell?
What did you teach her?
I taught her good English.
What do you mean?
Good English.
This is international collab.
We have Chinese, English, Japanese.
Okay.
We are going to learn new words today.
We are going to be good teachers.
Okay, how do we play?
I never played before.
I have never played only once.
I never played.
You guys are professionals.
You guys never played?
No, they played.
We played a little bit, Nachan and I.
Little bit.
Teach me.
Teach us.
Anything for the views.
Yeah, anything.
We are going to go viral.
Go viral.
Okay.
Go down to old world, film something scary.
Who is going to die first?
Someone has to die for views.
Me?
Why me?
It should be you.
You are late.
You were late.
You should die first.
Who is going to get the camera?
Light.
Camera.
Okay.
Wait, there is battery.
How do you charge battery?
Here.
You can charge battery here.
Oh, here.
How do I do that?
Stand here.
Oh, I charged it.
Let's go.
Let's be streamers.
We are going to be famous guys.
Wait, there is something here.
There is a green screen here.
Oh, really?
Oh.
Oh, right.
You can change the light.
What's the emote?
I know there is emotes too.
Let's emote.
T.
Okay.
Oh, I don't have emote.
I don't have money.
Hello, everybody.
Wait, film me.
Film me.
You guys, here.
Here.
Okay.
I will give you a sign.
One.
Two.
Three.
Go.
Hello, everybody.
Today, Ditto.
Today, Ditto is going to die.
Okay, I'm done.
Okay.
What the...
I need to...
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
I stopped.
My game was crazy.
I died.
I'm done.
How do we go?
I need post-it.
Submerge.
Is this it?
Submerge?
Door?
Okay.
Here we go.
Okay, let's go.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is this?
What the...
Yeah.
Alright.
You can see your stamina on the...
Oh, I see.
Yay, I see.
Okay.
I'm ready.
So, we need to just make content, right?
Yes.
Yes, yes, okay.
Someone dies...
You get lots of views, right?
When someone dies?
Yeah, we're gonna go into this house!
Let's go!
I'm dead.
No, we're not dead!
We're alive!
This is so...
Holy shit, this echo.
Oh my god.
That's so volume.
Okay.
Don't worry, we're okay.
That's so scary.
It's not scary.
Yeah, it's not scary.
Look at this, it's just a house.
Okay.
Yeah, it's a factory.
Okay, okay.
Don't worry, I won't get lost.
Follow me, follow me, follow me!
I know how to make content!
Follow you, follow you!
Yeah, follow me, follow me!
I'm content master.
Follow me, follow me!
Hello?
Monster?
Okay, no, no, this way, this way.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh my god!
What?
Are you okay?
Wait, wait, wait!
She's...
Wait!
What the heck is this?
What's this?
You killed her!
Wait, this is the game!
Hello.
Hey guys.
Oh, hey, hey.
Hey guys, welcome to my channel.
This is my best friend.
Ah!
That's not my best friend!
That's my best friend!
Okay.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Wait, wait, Hiro!
Where are you, Hiro?
Okay, I'm recording.
Ah!
No, no, no!
Okay, okay, okay.
Hello everybody.
Welcome to my channel.
This is my best friend, Gary.
And like today, he and I...
He's gonna give us a tour of the factory.
Okay, we follow...
Okay.
Oh my god.
Look, he's...
Alright,
I'm okay.
Yeah.
Go back, go back.
Alright, alright.
No, no, we gotta make more content!
We go see.
Follow me, follow me!
Oh!
Downstairs?
No, no, no.
He just loves hugging.
Oh, there's the exit.
There's the exit.
Oh!
What?
Wait, is he...
Is he nice?
What the hell?
Oh my god.
Okay, wait, I need to turn down my game volume.
Okay, okay, I turned it down.
Wait, is he nice?
What's up?
Get home.
Where did he go?
I have 0% battery.
He's right there!
Oh, wait, wait.
Did you film him?
Film him, film him!
Hello guys.
Welcome.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I can't...
I can't see him.
You can't see him?
You don't see him?
Yeah, I don't see him.
He don't...
He don't see him?
He's right in front of you!
Ditto!
I don't see!
Come here!
Give me the camera!
I can see him.
No, it's a person.
Oh, is it full?
Oh no!
Our content!
What is that?
I don't see!
It's just a little boy.
It's a little boy and he's like...
He's gone.
He doesn't like you.
Alright, our first...
Our first video, guys.
Our first video.
Hahaha.
Wait.
God, okay.
That's so loud!
I can't hear the sound.
You couldn't hear it?
It was so loud!
Yeah, he was like...
He was like...
I can't hear!
No!
Nachan, you're back!
Nachan, how did you die?
Welcome back!
How did you die?
I think you died.
Okay, let's see.
Let's see what the video is like.
Alright.
I got the CD.
I got it.
Come here, come here, come here.
Alright.
Hello!
Hello, everybody!
Today, Jeno's going to die!
Okay, I'm done.
Lots of views, right?
When someone dies.
Yeah!
We're gonna go into this house!
I'm gonna follow you!
Okay.
Don't worry, we're okay.
Yeah, follow me, follow me!
Follow me!
Follow you!
Follow me, follow me!
What's that?
What's this?
Monster?
Wait, she's dead!
What is this?
What the heck is this?
You're cute!
Wait, there's something here!
Wait!
Hey guys.
Welcome to my channel.
This is my best friend.
You're my best friend!
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Wait, wait, Jeno!
Wait, Jeno!
I'm recording, I'm recording.
No, no, no, no!
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to my channel.
This is my best friend.
Gary.
And today, he and I...
He's gonna give us a tour of the factory.
Alright, hey.
Oh!
We made $135!
Yay!
Yay, money!
What was the comments?
Please do more of this kind of video.
Honestly...
Oh!
Honestly, I really like Hiro-chan's voice!
Now, Chan looks dead.
Oh my god!
You have fans, Hiro!
Hiro, you're gonna be famous!
Oh my god!
Famous!
I achieved my dream of 1,000 views.
Oh my god!
Guys, subscribe!
So we can get 1,000 subscribers for Hiro!
Can we sleep, guys?
We sleep.
Yeah, time to sleep.
Time to sleep.
How do I sleep?
One day.
Did I sleep?
Sleep here.
Wait, did I sleep yet?
Not yet.
Okay, wait.
This is my bed.
This is your bed?
It's my bed.
What?
Why are you guys not asleep?
Go sleep!
Okay, I'll sleep here then.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'll sleep.
I'll sleep.
Okay, okay.
I'm sleeping.
Sleep, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I sleep.
Sleep time.
I was just trying to give a exclusive content.
Good morning!
Today is another hard day of work.
Can we buy stuff now?
Yeah, we can buy.
What can we buy?
This is a monster's gift.
I'll give it back.
Thank you!
Oh!
I got the camera.
Wait, who wants...
Oh, selfie mode.
Oh, okay, okay.
You can buy light kick.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What do we buy?
Are you spending money on emotes?
Are you guys...
No, no, no!
Are you emotes?
We want to waste our money.
Yeah, we're not gonna waste our money, guys.
Okay.
Wait,
wait.
Hug her, hug her, hug her.
Wait, somebody bought...
Who bought it?
Aida bought this!
I did.
No!
Oh my god!
Okay, okay.
Can someone film me?
Film me, film me, film me.
Film me, guys.
Okay.
Nice clapping, nice clapping.
This is $100.
That is $100 of clapping.
Nice!
Thank you.
Okay, don't worry, we can make it back.
That is... that will get us like 500 viewers.
This will be 500 viewers, guys.
Oh, yeah.
Don't worry.
Okay, um...
Do you remember the monster that we met yesterday?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
The person is not this kind.
He's... he's very weak.
Yes.
Oh, what the f...
What the f... He's really weak?
Okay.
Wasn't there another...
Let's find the little boy.
Damage.
Oh, okay.
That's good.
Alright, don't worry, guys.
Follow me, follow me.
Okay, okay.
Follow me.
I can clap.
Okay, we find the little boy.
Thank you.
Don't worry.
There's no fall damage.
Look at that.
We're fine.
We're okay.
No fall damage.
We'll be fine.
Oh, what's this?
Wait.
Huh?
What is that?
Oh, it's a head.
You gave me head.
Okay.
Which one?
Ah.
Don't worry.
Oh, wait.
That's scary.
Film something scary.
Wait.
What's that?
What's that over there?
Whoa!
What's that?
Don't touch.
Okay?
Okay.
Instantly?
Something there.
Which one?
There's something there.
Do you see it?
Yeah.
Wait.
Where's...
I clapped and I died.
Wait.
He's dead.
He's
dead.
He's into the laser.
I can't believe it.
I clapped to death.
Wait.
He's gone.
I hope you guys are okay.
I hope the wall... You guys are dying from the wall.
Hey.
Sound guy.
Are you okay?
I can't believe no one recorded it.
He's crying.
This way.
Okay.
Let me turn it down.
I can turn it down.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
There you go.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I could laugh to die.
That was so bullshit!
Ambient... okay.
There should be a way to turn down the fucking echo.
How the fuck do you turn down the echo?
Oh my god, what's over there?
What's over there?
Oh, that's the guy that slapped me!
Oh no!
That's the guy that fucking slapped me!
Oh my god!
He's got a knife!
Oh my god.
Okay, maybe I'll turn...
Okay, I'm gonna turn down here.
Is it sound effects?
Is anyone recording?
Nico!
Wait, did everyone dead?
Oh no!
Oh, that's how...
What is that?
Wait, Nacha's dead!
Oh, the echo did not change.
Poor sound guy.
There's no way to fix the echo.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
That's Ness!
It was just like, where do I go?
Oh my
god, they're alive!
Oh my god!
Where is Na-chan?
What the?
Where is Doki?
What happened to... where is Doki?
Yeah, my voice.
Why were they like, where is Na-chan?
What about me?
What the fuck?
Why were you guys like, oh my god.
Why were you guys like, where is Na-chan?
What happened to, where is Doki?
You guys didn't care about Doki.
Yeah, yeah, no one ever asked where Doki is.
Okay, I'm ready.
This is $100.
This is $100 of caffeine.
I wonder if Doki is having fun.
What is that?
I gave you head.
Oh, it's a head.
Oh, but there's something there.
Oh my god.
Which one?
There's something there.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
There's Doki.
What is that?
She's there.
Okay, okay.
Wait, what?
Why is she leaving?
What is that?
Oh, what is that?
You're crying.
Why are you just dancing?
Oh my god.
We did it.
We made $200.
Thank you both, guys.
Wait, we've done so much.
Yeah, yeah, we can buy more stuff now.
Let's go.
It's so much fun now.
Yeah, yeah, shop time.
Shopping, shopping.
It's shopping time!
Go back!
Oh wait!
Okay sorry, it's sleeping time!
We can't shopping!
But I wanna shop!
We have two prints in bed for it.
So go to bed first.
This is my bed!
But I wanna sleep here.
So sleep!
I wanna sleep here!
I'm blue!
She's terrible!
I sleep.
Sleep time!
See you tomorrow!
Money time tomorrow!
Time for more money!
Okay don't worry!
Okay!
Ditto!
You buy for us!
Here this one!
Hugger!
Hug?
Can we hug like... Oh!
What does hugger do?
Um...
It can heal your friend.
Oh!
Oh my god!
We should get...
We should get a mic!
Yeah this one here!
Hug!
I bought something!
Yeah!
What?
Watch this!
Yeah!
Okay I wanna hug!
Wait your mic is in the car!
My mic!
My huggy!
That's okay!
I have perfect weapon!
Your flashlight!
I do... I can do this!
Oh flashlight!
I can push people away!
Take the flashlight!
Yeah I got flashlight!
Are you ready?
Okay!
I'm getting you!
Who's gonna free me?
Now!
Yeah Nachan!
Nachan!
Nachan you film!
Okay, I'm ready.
Natchan, you film.
Go, go, go, go, go.
I'm ready.
Yes, ready too.
Don't worry, we make lots of money.
Natchan, I believe in you, Natchan!
I believe in you, Natchan!
You can see the battery.
You can see the camera's battery.
If it runs out of battery, we can't see anything.
Okay.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing him!
I'm pushing him away!
Okay, I hugged him!
Did
you hug?
Did you hug him?
Did you hug?
I can't hug you.
Did you hug him?
Leave me alone!
Leave, leave, leave, leave!
Leave!
Okay, don't worry.
We'll be fine, we're fine.
We gave him a hug.
It's okay.
We gave him a hug now.
Is your HP okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was not a tight hug.
Can someone heal me?
Wait, how do you heal?
How do we heal?
Oh.
Okay, I'm gonna...
How does this feel?
How does...
Is this...
Yeah, it's like a scare.
Do you need a hug, Nachan?
Okay, I'm okay now.
Do you need a hug?
Here's a hug.
Hello, Nachan.
Oh my god!
What is that?
Someone hug me!
It's here, it's here, it's here!
Hug me, hug me!
Hello.
Alright.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're okay.
We have hugs now.
We have hugs.
Alright.
Did we film the...
The gun?
Oh yeah, we can film the gun.
Wait, but this... What's this?
Oh, look!
Look!
Here, film this!
Yeah, film!
Wow!
Okay, that's good.
So beautiful!
Wow!
Oh, there's another laser!
Look,
there's two!
There's three!
Don't worry!
I'll protect you guys!
Oh, oh!
No, no, no, I can't protect you guys!
Oh, there's more!
Okay, I'm leaving.
Goodbye!
Ah!
Oh, there are all of them!
Oh!
Guys?
Okay.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I turned around.
Guys!
Guys, what a... Guys, oh!
Okay, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good!
Okay!
Okay.
Guys?
Oh, no.
No!
Please!
Somebody help me!
What the fuck is that?
Oh, that's just...
Okay.
Guys, do you guys think they'll find me?
If I just...
Maybe if I just hide in this corner?
That everything will be okay?
Everything?
What?
It's okay.
I have my... I have my...
Guys, it's okay.
They'll come back for me, right?
They're...
They're gonna come back for me, right, guys?
Hello?
Surely they'll come back for me.
Surely I'm important enough for them to rescue me.
Right?
No, no, no.
This isn't...
I left four deads in there.
Oh, my God.
I'm so fucked.
Oh, my God, I'm so fucked.
Guys!
I'm so fucked.
I'm gonna do a merry-go-round.
Oh, my God, they don't know.
They don't know to aggro to somebody else.
They know, they know, they know.
This is a hell, Mary.
There's no way I die to this laser.
There's no way.
You know what?
Down is up.
I fucking...
I fucking knew it.
Down is up!
Down is always up!
No way!
Down is up!
We're gonna make it!
Wait.
How do I...
How do I close this?
How do I close the door?
Oh, no.
So, how do I...
How do I close the door?
Why...
Why isn't...
Why isn't the door closed?
I broke it!
Oh, no.
Oh.
Where are my comrades?
The others... Are they still alive?
Are they still alive?
I don't believe...
It won't be funny.
Ditto?
Hitto?
Not yet?
It will be pretty funny.
But what if I die?
I need the camera.
You'll lose if I do.
Oh, no.
But where are... Are they still alive?
But where are...
Are they still alive?
164...
100...
They're still like...
Oh, they're still fucking dead.
We do not have the oxygen for this, guys.
We do not have the oxygen.
Oh, they're out of ox...
Wait, how do...
How do I have more ox...
Oh, is it because I went up?
Oh yeah, they're fucking dead dead.
They're not even moving.
He saw me, he saw me.
He saw me.
Noooo!
No!
I didn't do it!
It wasn't closed!
I tried to close...
Wait until you close the door.
I tried to close and it wasn't close.
It was just a bad dream, everybody.
Just a really bad dream.
It's okay, it's okay.
We still have our channel.
We're gonna be big YouTube stars.
We're gonna be big streamers.
We're gonna be big Twitch streamers, big YouTube, big Billy Billy streamers.
We're gonna be famous.
Yeah, really.
We are Spooktober, okay?
We're gonna be big.
Spooktober.
We're gonna be big Spooktober.
We're going viral.
World tour.
World tour international.
We are content gods.
It's okay, we can do it again.
Let's go.
Wait, do we have the hug?
No, we don't.
We have no hug?
It's okay, guys.
Do you know what we do have?
Can you...emotes?
Okay, are you filming?
They may have taken our hug, but I'll still clap.
I'll still clap.
The most emo...
Emo is forever.
Let me explain the game.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, this game.
The camera is very important.
Yeah.
More than our life.
We have to save more than our life.
Yeah.
Okay, that's not my fault.
You guys died.
I lived.
No.
June.
She ran away.
I ran away?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no.
You.
You left me.
I did not run away.
You guys left me to die.
No.
Left for dead.
And now it's our next day.
Okay.
Let's get her back.
Hey, Gary.
Yeah.
He shouldn't be outside.
Why he's outside?
Because he wants...
Because he wants to welcome us.
He's our best friend.
Oh, I'm so nice.
Our best friend.
All right.
Yeah.
If we are...
If we launch the monster, it's gonna run away again.
That's not true.
You all ran away from me.
You guys ran away from me.
Hiro.
Hiro, Nata, and me.
We have to get out of here.
Yeah.
And all three of you ran away from me.
You guys are...
No, no, no, no, no.
I don't run away.
I'm not a cat.
What...
What is that?
Film.
Film it.
Go on.
What's going
to...
He's not...
He's not this kind.
Okay.
Come here.
Follow me.
See.
I didn't run away.
I didn't run away, guys.
Okay, guys.
Follow me, follow me.
Okay, nothing.
Okay, okay.
Back here, back here.
Don't... Follow me, follow me, follow me.
Oh, it's here.
Oh, it's him again.
He's back.
Look, there he is.
Where is it?
Hey, Hiro's dead.
Hiro's dead.
Hiro...
Hiro died.
Hiro?
Yeah, yeah.
No, she's dead.
She's dead.
I watched her die.
Oh, oh, she... Nachan, Nachan.
Oh, look at what Nachan got.
Nachan.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Follow me, follow me.
Oh, I got one too.
Look, look, look.
Whoa.
Oh, so cool.
Cool.
Down is up.
We're back here.
We're back in the beginning.
Okay.
We were here, right?
Yeah, we were here.
Okay, I'm going up.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
He missed, he missed, he missed, he missed, he missed.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I'm going.
Yeah, yeah.
Go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
We leave Nachsan, we leave Nachsan.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
It's okay, it's okay.
If Nachan dies, it's okay.
It's okay.
No, no, no.
She's dead, she's dead.
She's dead.
No, no, no.
She's so dead.
Nachan!
I knew you were...
You didn't die, Nachan.
Natchan, congrats!
I'm so happy you're alive!
She keeps telling me fake news.
No, it's real!
What do you mean?
No!
It was real.
She's still alive!
No, no, no, she came back!
It's like Jesus.
She came back.
I see.
Yeah, Natchan's like Jesus.
Natchan, are you God?
No die!
Yeah, see?
Okay, no die.
Yeah, look at that.
Right here, right here.
Alright.
Oh, she's dead.
No, she's dead.
I watched her die.
Yay!
Goodbye, Hiro.
Goodbye.
Let's welcome back Hiro.
Hiro!
Welcome back!
I'm a ghost!
Hiro, I saw that.
I saw you run into the laser.
I was like, ooh, laser.
Ooh, laser.
My name is Owen Fraser and I...
How is our stream?
We're gonna be famous, guys.
We're gonna be famous.
Are you the lady?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Okay.
That's nice.
Okay, okay.
Hold on.
You ready?
Yeah.
Why is he all night?
Because he wants us.
And he wants to welcome us.
Hiro, Natchan, and me.
We are...
Hiro-chan.
We're going, we're going, we're going.
We're going!
I'm a ghost!
Oh, I'm a ghost!
No,
no, no!
I'm a ghost!
I'm so scared!
Hiro's dead.
He's gonna die.
Oh!
Nachan!
Yeah!
Look at
him!
We need
Nachan!
It's okay!
If Nachan dies, it's okay!
It was okay!
Look!
We got... we got...
one...
one dot nine K.
We're almost at three hundred dollars!
Yeah, we almost did it.
Yay!
Good morning!
Good morning, guys!
Okay.
Good morning!
Another day of making...
content!
Soaping, soaping!
Let's collect it down.
Yeah, we need a hugger.
We need a hugger.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
One hugger.
And one flashlight.
All flashlight.
Okay.
Wait, do we still have money?
Yeah, we do.
We have like... we have a hundred seventy-two.
Let's play the soundboard.
Oh yeah, the soundboard.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good, good, good purchase.
Here, here, here.
Okay, flashlight, flashlight.
What else should we get?
We should have... how much do we have?
Seventy dollars?
Can we afford anything?
Oh my god!
Yeah?
What's this?
I think we're gonna be in the red.
Oh, okay, wait, wait, wait.
I ordered something that I really want.
What did you buy?
That's it.
I already used it.
We should buy another one!
I didn't know it was one use!
No one told me it was one use!
There it is!
Okay, okay, okay.
When we...
When we survive...
Okay, I know when to use this.
When we survive, I'll use this.
Look, I have a soundboard.
What's this?
It's a soundboard!
Oh, you're like... you're like the sound player.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I help the sound player.
Wait, what's this?
It's evil.
How to...
What is that?
Help me!
What is this?
What are you doing?
I don't know!
I don't know.
Are you like, flying?
You're flying!
Alright, let's go!
Let's film content!
It's content time!
I have high gear so I can heal you guys.
Alright, nice.
I love heals.
Okay.
I have...
I have a...
Big Bang Theory.
Alright, don't worry.
That scared me, actually!
Cool transition.
Oh my god, I don't like the song.
Oh, this is gonna make everything sound good!
Ba-dum-ba-dum!
Yo, be careful!
That speed box.
Okay, don't worry.
When it's funny, I'll play this.
So everyone will know it's funny.
Everyone will know it's funny.
I feel like that's...
It's face carry!
Alright,
here we go.
Alright.
I should have incorporated that.
Oh, that's a lot of lasers.
Wait, wait, wait!
I got it!
I got an idea!
Okay.
Let's go!
You got this!
Umm...
Oh!
Did you record it?
I did!
You did?
Okay, nice, nice.
Content!
Okay.
I can do this too.
Can you?
Nice,
look at us.
We're so good!
We're already so...
Yay!
Alright.
We need to find some monsters for content.
Oh, there's a head here.
I haven't seen any monsters yet.
Follow me, follow me.
I'm so good at finding monsters.
Oh, here, here, here!
Crouch down.
There we go.
Oh, there's two!
There's two!
Are
you filming?
Are you playing music?
Where's our cameraman?
Wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait, oh, I got an idea!
Okay, okay, film me, film me, film me!
Film me!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Film me.
Okay, right here.
Okay.
Wait, we need to get Gary out of the picture.
Get Gary out.
Okay, okay, okay.
Film me here.
Are you filming?
Got it?
Okay.
It was worth it.
Yeah, you got that?
Okay.
Okay, we got, we got caught.
Oh my god, he's following me.
Blame the man, I have to blame the man.
Oh, okay, oh, okay, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, we're back in the beginning.
Wait, is there anything else here?
I think this is a new area.
Teto-chan, HP.
Yeah, what's your HP?
Do you need hug?
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, we can hug you.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, I can hug you.
Okay.
Wait, film us, film us hugging.
Are you filming us hugging?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, Na-chan, film.
Ready?
Okay.
Hello.
What?
What happened?
Okay, okay, okay, let's go.
Let's sleep, let's sleep.
Let's go, let's sleep, let's sleep.
Let's sleep.
Go, go, go, go, go.
The monster wanted a hug too.
Maybe we can hug now.
Yeah, we can hug.
Oh my gosh.
I got like 10 HP.
10 HP was gone.
Yeah?
Where are I'm...
This way, this way.
Come, come, come, come, come.
Come, come, come, this way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, she knows where.
I found you.
Ma, ma, ma.
What do you mean?
We found her.
We found it.
We're home.
We did it.
Whoa.
Oh!
It's okay, it's okay.
Same guy, same guy.
Yeah, it's okay.
We can run, we can run.
Yeah, we can run.
Yay!
See, we're faster.
Don't worry, Nachan.
Come on, come, come, come, come.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
I can run.
It's okay, there's no more monster.
All right.
Do you still have film?
Nachan, do you still have film, Nachan?
Nachan?
Do you...
Mm-hmm.
We did it.
Zero.
Zero?
Okay.
I think we got it.
I like how Hiro's bill, hospital bill is one dollar.
Hello!
Hello, Hiro!
How did you die?
They, they, they comboed me.
Oh, they smashed you in the wall?
Yeah.
Okay.
Does anyone else want to do sound?
And hug?
All right.
You guys ready?
Let's go.
Let's watch.
.
Are you flying?
You're flying.
.
Yeah, we can.
Nice.
That's good to know.
Yeah.
Like, um, tomorrow we frame the, um, the video and we don't play it and we will play it in a few days.
Oh!
We can stack the videos.
.
Shopping time!
Shopping!
Guys, it's time to shop.
.
What are you buying?
I'm gonna buy something really helpful.
Really?
It will be really helpful.
I swear.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Watch.
So we know when to film.
.
Watch this.
Lights!
Camera!
Action!
.
Are you ready?
Are you ready to film?
Okay, okay, okay.
Na-chan, Na-chan, are you ready?
Yeah, yeah?
Okay.
Three, two, one.
.
Whoa!
So good!
That's so good, Na-chan!
Professional.
So professional.
Wait, wait, we need this then.
We need this.
.
Okay.
Na-chan, what do you want to say, Na-chan?
.
Go.
Go, Na-chan, say something!
Say something!
You're on camera!
Go.
.
What?
What did I say?
It's like, um...
.
What does it do?
Oh!
Is it one use?
.
Oh, it's one use!
Oh my god, it's so slow!
I guess it slows people down.
.
Yeah, it's so sticky!
Oh!
I see, I see.
.
Let's buy more.
Yeah, we have a hundred dollars so we can buy.
.
I can take it because the slot is full.
Yeah, I can take one.
.
Okay, I'm gonna order it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
.
Victory!
Alright, I got one.
Alright, are we gonna...
.
Wait, what?
What?
.
What did you say?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
.
Yeah, Doki is gonna die first.
Oh, hey, who wants to be Mike?
.
Oh, oh, Hiro is the interviewer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm the MC.
.
I'll interview, I'll interview.
Okay, interview the monsters.
Interview the monsters when we see them.
.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Here we go.
.
Welcome back.
Like and subscribe.
.
The laughing is so scary.
We need to find monsters to interview.
.
We have five monsters to interview.
Oh, God, that's so scary.
That's so spooky.
.
What's over there?
There's lasers here.
.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can't get past that.
That one we can't get past.
.
So maybe here?
Oh, there's a rib cage.
.
Are you filming?
Oh,
there's another one.
.
This place is like a maze.
Where are all the monsters?
.
I found zero monsters.
We need to fucking interview one.
.
Use your content, monster.
All the monsters are scared of us.
Why are they so scared?
.
Monster.
Let us use you for content.
We want to be famous YouTubers.
.
And streamers.
And Billy streamers and Twitch streamers.
.
Oh my god, there's actually zero monsters.
We have found zero.
.
Oh no, we need to find the monsters.
Okay.
All right, we got speed run.
There has to be one person.
.
Let us use you for views.
Oh, I found the entrance.
.
How is there nobody?
How do we have no one?
.
There's a laser here.
What the fuck was that?
.
What was that?
What the fuck was that?
What the fuck is this?
.
Yeah, what the fuck is that?
Wait, what?
.
I didn't even see it.
I think we need to...
.
Yeah, I didn't see anything either.
It just exploded in front of me.
.
How do we get out of here?
Oh my god, I'm lost, guys.
.
We're so lost.
Wait.
.
Where's Hiro?
Hiro?
.
Yeah, where's Hiro?
Hiro?
.
Where's our interview?
What is that?
.
That's a radio.
Yeah, it's a radio.
.
Film it.
Oh, she's gone.
.
Goodbye.
I think... .
.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have to go back.
.
Nachan, Nachan, she's dead.
Nachan.
.
Come back, Nachan.
Leave her, leave her, leave her.
.
You have the camera, right?
Yeah.
.
Nachan, come, come, come.
We leave.
.
She's dead.
It's okay.
.
She's dead.
We have to leave.
.
Be careful, be careful.
We can go there.
.
We leave her for content.
It's okay.
.
She gave us good content.
From zero monsters to like... .
Oh my god, oh my god.
.
I hate you.
Oh, and then.
.
We're doing it.
Okay, guys, go, go, go.
.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
.
Yeah.
It's okay.
.
We didn't lose anything.
Is that just... .
Okay, let's stop playing.
.
What is that?
This way, this way, this way.
.
So, from zero monsters to all monsters.
That was so fucking crazy.
.
That was crazy.
Eh, Nacha?
.
Hey!
Okay, now we leave.
.
Well, it looks like... .
It's Hiro!
.
No, I think, no, Hiro's... .
Definitely dead.
No, she's... .
She's gone.
.
It was for content.
Okay.
.
Wait.
It's just a prank.
.
Okay.
Oh, she was like zero dollars.
.
Hiro was zero dollars.
That's good.
.
Welcome back, Hiro.
It dragged me to the lasers.
.
Oh, you died to the lasers?
The slime took me to the lasers!
.
It took me there and I died!
What the hell?
.
Look, see, I didn't die first.
I didn't die first, guys.
.
All right.
Oh, we can stack.
.
Oh, yeah, yeah, we don't... .
We don't need a... .
Okay.
.
Oh, so smart.
Yeah, because we... .
Yeah, tensai.
We already got our money.
.
But we don't have money, okay?
It's okay.
We'll have money next time.
.
Okay, good morning.
Good morning, everybody.
.
Good morning.
Are you guys ready to make more content?
.
Yeah!
Time for more content!
.
All right, we don't... .
We can't afford anything, though.
.
We're poor now.
Oh, yeah, we have one dollar.
.
Yeah, yeah, we have one dollar.
We can't afford anything for one dollar.
.
I need to charge my... .
I need to charge my flashlight.
.
Ditto is eating something.
No, what are you eating, Ditto?
.
What are you eating?
All right, let's go.
.
Let's go.
It's time to make more content.
.
Let's go.
It's time to make more content.
.
Content time!
We got to make money.
.
We need all the money.
Yeah, Hiro, don't die.
You're always dying, Hiro.
Hiro, you're always dying.
What do you mean?
Who spawns it?
Wait, what's this map?
Is this new map?
Oh, really?
How is it hard?
There's monsters!
Oh, it's not a snake!
It's a snake!
Film it!
Okay,
he's on the
left.
He's scared.
He's left.
Okay, wait, wait.
Who has hug?
Wait, wait.
We have hug.
I have hug.
Hug, hug, hug, hug, hug.
Yes, yay!
Yay!
Okay, okay.
I'm full.
Oh, Hiro!
Hiro!
Hiro, Hiro, you need hug!
Hug Hiro!
You gotta hug Hiro!
Oh my god!
It's okay.
He ran away.
He got scared.
Finish him back.
Oh my god.
Alright, alright.
It's okay.
He got scared.
Someone hug me!
Okay, okay, okay.
I can't hug.
I don't like personal touch.
Hug, hug, hug, hug.
Nice.
Thank you.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Nachan, do you need hug?
Oh, wait.
Nachan discovered something.
No!
No, don't do it!
I'm gonna do it.
Film me.
It's a hole.
Guys, film me!
I'm okay.
There's nothing wrong here.
It's just a hole.
Guys?
Did you film it at least?
Guys, jump down!
Oh no.
I don't think they jumped down, chat.
I don't think they jumped down.
It's okay.
I've done this before.
Down is up.
It's okay.
I've done this before.
Down is up.
Surely.
Okay, maybe not that down.
Maybe.
Maybe not that down.
Guys!
Hello?
Why didn't nobody jump down with me?
Oh no.
I can't believe it.
I did all of that for content and nobody filmed anything.
These are unprofessional content creators.
Am I the only one that takes my job seriously?
I don't like this.
Oh, I really don't like this.
Oh.
How the fuck do I get out of here?
Oh no.
I hope they don't leave me for dead.
Surely they won't, right?
Surely I'm more important to them, right?
Oh no.
Oh, I don't like this.
I'm so fucking dead, guys.
Wait, I hear you guys!
Where are you guys?
Oh!
I'm dead!
I did it!
Where is it?
Viva, we were dying to the 9th of September.
Wait, you were dying to the 9th of September?
I'm the only one.
I died like 100 HP.
Look at that.
I did all of that and you guys didn't film anything!
You guys didn't film anything.
I can't believe it.
We have to hide.
No.
What is that?
Oh my god!
Oh he hurts, he hurts, he hurts.
Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Come back, come back, come back, come back.
Wait, who has the camera?
Nachan, Nachan, leave her!
Nachan, leave her!
She's dead!
Nachan, she's dead!
Wait, Nachan's dead?
She has the flashlight.
Okay, let's go.
Let's leave, let's leave, let's leave.
Wait, did you film him already?
Yeah!
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Wait, wait, wait.
That one, the one that has big guy?
Yeah?
We can just flashlight to him, okay?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, if we just flashlight to him.
Oh, I see.
Okay, I need hugs.
Thank you.
Thank you for the hug.
Wait, I still have film.
Oh, you still have film?
Okay, okay, okay, we hug each other.
We end it with a hug.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, you still have film, right?
Nachan died!
It's okay, we don't have to pay money for her death.
That's the best part.
Alright, alright.
Wait, who has the hug?
I have one.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, wait.
Alright.
Someone hug and then we film it.
Okay.
Okay, I'll do the sound effects.
Someone... Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Okay, ready?
Three...
Okay, three, two, one.
That was...
That was great.
That was a great...
That was a great hug.
I'm 26 years old.
Emote, emote, emote.
Alright, there's more?
Wow!
Nachan's goals...
Yeah!
Emote, emote, emote time.
Emote, emote, emote.
Yay!
Wow!
Amazing!
Wait, wait, wait, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
Do you have more film?
Oh, shit.
I don't know.
3%.
Okay, okay, come here, come here, come here.
I got an idea.
Come here, come here, come here.
Come here.
Okay, okay, okay.
I saw this on the internet.
Okay, Ditto, get on the bed.
Okay.
Okay, are you ready to film?
Are you ready?
Did you lie down in bed?
Yeah, are you ready?
Are you ready?
Yeah.
What are you gonna do?
What is that?
Okay, okay.
Okay, nothing.
We didn't do anything.
What?
What are you doing?
I did nothing.
What?
I didn't do anything.
What was that?
Nothing.
It was nothing.
Wait, it's over the end.
It
was too spicy.
Oh, no!
The content was too spicy.
Really?
We got demonetized.
Oh, no!
Okay, okay, okay.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Wait, wait, wait.
We watched it yesterday.
Okay, okay, okay.
It was like yesterday.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, three, two, one.
Don't!
No!
What?
So good!
I wonder if nothing is the keyframe.
Wait, that's what you mean.
Huh?
Okay, I'll just do it.
I'll interview.
How do you feel?
Interview the monsters.
Interview the monsters when we see them.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah.
Alright.
How do you feel?
Oh, my God.
Don't make me look cool.
I'm all confused, me too.
Are you filming?
How do you feel today?
How do you feel today, sir?
I don't know.
I have zero monsters.
Yeah, we have...
We need to fucking interview one.
I'm all cool.
Are
you okay?
What was that?
Oh, this is when the thing exploded on us.
That's the radio.
Yeah.
First time.
First time I saw it.
Yeah, it's the radio.
Oh, thank...
It's like Tik Tok.
Dance, dance.
Yeah, we're doing Tik Tok dance.
That was a good cut.
We can save.
We can save the cut here.
I save the video.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Next video.
Learning hard.
I like hands.
You like hands?
What the fuck
is going on?
You saw film right?
Emo time!
Hey hey hey hey!
Wow!
That's amazing!
Amazing!
What the hell?
Do it!
I got an idea!
What the fuck?
This is frozen!
I thought it was painted red.
I was hugging!
What are you doing?
If you want to see the rest of it, you gotta get the...
Director's cut.
You know the director's cut.
Oh guys look!
Look!
Yeah!
Oh shit!
Can you pause this?
Oh my god!
Can we do it?
We made so much money!
Okay!
Come here!
It's sleep time!
Sleep time!
Okay I save the video.
Wow!
Good morning!
Good morning everybody!
I had a great time!
Hey wait!
We can... we can...
We can buy this one.
We can revive!
The revive one here!
Oh revive!
That's good!
Yeah defibrillator.
Yeah we can buy one.
Did you buy one yet?
Not yet!
Okay I'll buy.
We can revive three times in one game.
Okay and then...
I'm gonna buy...
Please don't die!
No the shock stick!
Okay.
Yeah don't die guys!
Don't die!
Do you wanna film today?
Oh yeah I wanna try filming!
Yeah yeah yeah!
Okay I'm gonna throw this.
And then...
I'm gonna throw this.
And then... No!
We don't have enough money for this!
Alright.
My turn to film.
Don't worry!
Don't worry.
I know how to make a good movie.
Alright I bought us a defibrillator.
This one is...
The one that you wanna buy first.
Which one?
This one?
Yeah.
This one.
Yeah I know.
Alright.
Are you guys ready to film?
Okay.
Alright.
We can do this.
We're gonna be famous!
Oh wait.
Wait wait wait wait!
You have to charge the battery.
Oh yeah yeah yeah!
Let me charge my phone.
Oh flashlight.
Yeah yeah yeah.
I'm gonna charge...
I'm gonna charge my battery... my flashlight.
Director Doki is here.
Alright.
Welcome to my documentary.
What did you order?
Wait what did you buy?
Did you buy that?
Are you guys ready?
Yeah!
Alright.
I'm ready.
Okay.
Let's go let's go.
This is gonna... we're gonna make so much money guys.
Oh my god!
I'm a lady!
My flashlight!
Oh.
Wait wait wait.
My flashlight.
What happens if we like...
Leave?
Kill me?
We're not allowed to leave.
Awwww.
We are not.
Unlucky.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I believe in us to make lots of money for this one.
Because I'm filming.
Alright let's go.
Alright.
Let's go!
Oh we're back here!
Okay guys guys guys come here come here come here.
Wait where's the hole?
Wait wait wait.
How do we open this hole?
I will teach you.
If you get caught.
You have to throw the item.
To this one.
Oh okay.
Alright here we go.
I'm gonna get caught.
Is she dead?
Is she?
Okay okay okay.
Okay okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god why is she going?
Hug me hug me hug me.
Hug me hug me.
Oh my god.
How do you open this hole?
How do we open this?
We can.
Oh we can?
There's no... Oh it's random.
Wait is there a hole here?
No there's no holes.
Alright let's go down.
You like holes?
Yeah yeah I like all the holes.
We go down.
No let's go all the way down guys.
All the way down.
That's where the real content is.
Down down down.
Go down.
That's it.
How do I know how much battery I have left?
Top right?
I think top right.
Oh I see it.
Okay.
Let's find some monsters.
What's that?
What is this?
Look at the point.
AHHHHH!
Who pushed me?
Wait wait wait she has the camera.
She has the camera.
Oh my god.
Who pushed me?
Me.
Go away.
Oh my god.
Why would they push the camera man?
Push push.
No.
It was an accident.
What is this?
Cairo Cairo let's go home.
They don't have the camera.
We have to find a way out of this.
I don't know.
I can't believe it.
I worked so hard on making such good content.
All my content.
My first directorial debut.
Hello.
They would do this to me.
Oh this way.
Yes.
This is what they get.
I'm glad I told them to all go downstairs.
I can't believe it.
My first directorial debut.
I hope Ditto dies.
Oh no.
Come here.
Wait what the fuck was that?
What the fuck was that?
What is that?
What was that?
I'm there.
No no no.
Ditto.
Oh my god.
This
one is easy.
Okay let's go.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Oh this way.
I remember this.
I remember these maze that I have to go through.
Okay okay let's go.
Let's go.
If I was still alive.
I would have take them home.
This was the exact same way I did to find my way home.
Okay.
Let's go.
How can they go home without the camera?
I can't believe they would survive.
I can't believe it.
They did not deserve it.
They did not deserve to live.
They should have died with me!
If they were true homies, they would die with me!
What the fuck?
Why is that so funny?
Holy shit!
What the fuck?
I can't believe it.
My hospital bill is 26?
Who pushed me?
Dedo!
I got it!
You know it's you!
It's you!
It was you!
Who else would it be?
I'm going to sleep.
Now I'm mad.
Rage video.
Sleepy sleeping.
Okay, wait.
It's me.
Sleepy!
Your face is so bad!
Goki's face.
Now I'm mad.
Look at her face.
Why are you mad?
Now I'm mad.
Now I hope we never become famous.
I hope we never become famous.
Oh no.
I have camera again.
Do we...
Film again, film again.
You dropped the last time.
Okay.
I'm mad now.
We have... okay, wait.
What do we have?
How much money do we have left?
Okay, we have...
234.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, we should!
Oh yeah, shopping time!
Shopping time!
Don't worry.
I got us content.
Yeah.
Watch this.
Content.
Can I film myself while doing this?
Can I do that?
I don't know.
We have no money.
We can?
Oh, $20?
Okay.
I lost it.
Alright, let's go.
You guys ready for content?
Okay, I'm ready!
Content time.
Let's go.
You know what?
Nachan, you should be leader.
Nachan.
Leader.
I'm leader?
Yeah, you're leader.
Yeah, you go.
You go.
We follow.
We follow you, Nachan.
Follow me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it's this again.
Oh, it's here again.
Where do we go, Nachan?
Okay.
Where do we go?
I'm following you.
We're following?
Whoa, look at all this.
What is this?
It's just glasses.
Glasses?
Where are the monsters, though?
Monsters.
Nachan.
Okay.
This time, someone should die for content, though.
We would get more money.
Wouldn't we get more money if somebody dies on camera?
I think so.
Yeah.
Nachan, as leader, you should do it.
Nachan.
You die.
Nachan, go die.
Go, yeah.
Yes, die.
Why is it you guys?
You guys.
Nachan, you should do it.
It'll be so funny.
It's a monster.
How can you tell Nachan go die, though?
No, no monster.
No monster.
Nachan.
Hi.
Hello.
Yeah?
What was it?
Hi.
Oh, we can go.
We can go now.
We can go.
Nice.
I'm a leader.
Yeah.
Okay, go.
Go.
Oh, what's that?
Nachan, touch it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Go touch it.
Oh.
Nachan, please.
I can't.
Come here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just hug after you touch it.
Wait.
What's that?
Hey.
Walk.
What was that?
This is monster.
Wow.
What is that?
That's a monster.
Did you see that?
Yes.
Nachan, are you there?
You're flaming.
Oh, Nachan.
Do you flame it?
Oh!
Okay.
Someone help me.
Champu, champu, champu, champu, champu, champu, champu, champu, champu.
Okay, okay.
Okay, someone hug me.
Wait, wait.
Who has hugged?
Hold on.
Hug me, hug me.
Yeah, hug me, yeah.
Nice, okay, I'm okay now.
Okay.
Hiro, Hiro, Hiro.
Hiro?
Is Hiro dead?
I think Hiro died.
Yeah.
I think she's dead.
Hiro?
Yeah, she's dead.
Wait, does she have the defibrillator?
Wait, who has it?
Who has the defib?
Yeah, she has it.
We have to go back to...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, revive.
Yeah, we can revive her.
Oh, there she is.
There's her dead body.
Before you revive her.
What's that?
Okay, someone revive her.
I'll film.
Film?
Yeah.
Revive!
Let's go!
She's reviving!
Oh, shit!
Fuck, okay!
Oh, my God!
I'm dead.
Did you get died?
Oh, my God!
I heard you were revived.
I didn't die.
I'm gonna revive you.
Oh, I'm okay!
I'm okay!
I'm okay now, guys.
I'm okay.
Alright, let's go.
He don't heal.
He don't die again.
We gotta get out of here!
I'm
going up!
It's okay.
Nacha, are you okay?
No!
No, I'm okay!
Okay, Nacha!
Okay, okay, okay.
We're good.
We can revive her.
Okay, okay.
Yes, hug.
Okay, okay, okay.
Here you go.
I'm good.
Hug me too.
I can hug.
Don't worry.
Okay, okay.
Am I hugging?
Okay.
Okay, wait, but watch this.
One more!
Okay, alright.
We're good.
Alright, alright.
I'll wait for you.
I'll wait here.
Okay.
Because we have to go anyway.
Are we going to let... Are we going to revive Hiro?
No, we can't because it's still battling.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Let's leave.
Let's go.
Where do we go?
Wait, Nacha!
Leader!
No, no, no, no, no.
Nacha, leader!
Why not?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
No, no, no, no, no.
Nacha!
We have to go back.
Okay, okay, okay.
Go home.
Yeah, yeah.
Home time.
If we run out of the ocean, we will die too.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That's true.
We have to... Home time.
I believe in you.
This way, this way, this way.
Oh, okay.
I think this way.
We can do this.
Okay.
Wait, where?
We go up.
Where is home?
We're gonna die.
Nice.
Oh, nice!
We're not gonna die.
Left side, left side.
Wait, I know this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We go here and then right.
And then...
Left, left, left, left.
Yeah, yeah, I memorized this.
And then...
Is this way?
We go forward?
Yeah!
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm a genius.
I'm a genius, guys, by the way.
Subscribe to Doki Bird at YouTube.
I'm fucking...
I'm never lost.
No, no, no!
Nice!
Okay, okay.
Guys, guys, guys, before we go, let's...
Let's film ourselves real fast.
Guys, guys, guys, look.
All right, are you guys ready?
Okay.
Hero died.
What a loser.
Okay, no more.
Hiro!
Hiro, are you back?
Hiro's back guys!
Hiro's back!
Where's Hiro?
Hiro?
Where is she?
Oh Hiro!
I found Hiro!
I found her!
Okay, she was hiding secretly.
Don't worry guys, I filmed something amazing.
You're gonna love it.
How do I put this?
Do I just throw it?
Are we gonna play it today?
Yeah, today.
No, no, no, no, today.
We need it.
Don't worry.
You guys will know why we play it today.
Okay, you guys are gonna love it.
You guys are gonna love it.
This is my best work.
You guys will love it.
Okay.
Can you?
That's so fast!
Let's play this!
Don't worry!
Chug!
Boy, she died.
Where's Hiro?
No!
I'm going up!
It's...
Hey!
No!
Come here!
I'm not talking to you!
Go, go, go, go, go!
You can't go up!
Uh-oh!
Let's try.
Hiro's home.
Go up!
It's so perfect!
It's beautiful!
Chainsaw!
Subscribe to Jokey Bird.
I have a new channel.
Hiro's back!
Hiro!
30 ,000 people!
So many people watched us!
Yeah, so many people.
Yeah.
Oh!
300 dollars!
I made us 300 dollars!
Wow!
Yes!
Look at that!
We're ready!
We already won!
We made a quota!
I made so much money.
I'm so good.
Good morning!
Beautiful day.
We did it!
Look at us.
We're making so much money.
Alright, who wants to film next?
Okay, Hiro.
Alright, Hiro.
How much money do we have?
What's 320?
Should we save our money?
Okay, I need a flashlight.
Yeah, I need a flashlight though.
I saved the channel.
What are you guys gonna get?
Well, I don't have any emote yet.
Yeah, you should buy an emote.
Yeah, buy an emote.
For more content.
Backflip!
300!
Oh, it's 300.
Yeah, we can afford it.
300 exactly!
Oh, wait, we should get rid of the part...
Yeah, wait.
Why did you add two party profit?
Oh my god!
Alright, nice.
Let's try it.
Alright.
I'll try.
Oh my god, you should film yourself doing a backflip.
It's gonna look good.
Yeah, film yourself with a backflip.
What will it look like?
Oh!
What the...
Oh my god, that was beautiful.
That was...
10 out of 10.
It was so beautiful.
Did I do it?
Yeah, yeah.
No, no.
Yeah, you did.
You did.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
You definitely did.
You definitely did, Yerro.
It was...
Are you flaming?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She filmed it.
Yeah, I did!
Oh, okay.
That was nice.
It was so sick.
It was like the best backflip I've ever seen.
Wow!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Is this the same map or a new map?
Oh, it's this map.
Yeah, it's this map.
Okay.
Guys, I can't die because I have Hug.
You need me.
I need you.
You guys need me.
Wee!
Yay, I have Hug.
I have Hug.
I can Hug anybody.
Hug for heroes.
I can hug anybody too.
Monster.
Monster!
We wanna make content!
Monster?
Monster!
Would you wanna be interviewed, Monster?
Cool!
Oh, what's this?
Wait, what is that?
Cool!
It's a ToriBee.
A famous monster for our channel.
Look at this.
Woah!
This is Doki!
Doki!
Yeah, this is me.
Woah!
You can buy it for 5.99.
Subscribe to DokiBird.
Cheap!
I know.
So cheap.
It's almost the same price as a membership.
That's how cheap it is.
What is this?
There's a monster.
We need to make money.
I heard if we stay longer, there would be bigger monsters.
Yeah, we just have to stay longer for bigger monsters to show up.
Monster!
I think we're not...
No, we want to see big monsters.
Big monsters equals more views.
Oh, there's more!
There's more!
There's more spines!
Film it!
I can... Look at all these spines.
Woah!
This will make good soup!
Good soup!
I'm gonna put it in my soup base.
Wait, how do... Is this Dead End?
Where's door?
Oh, the sword!
Sword!
Bye-bye!
Hug is here!
Oh, she's dead.
Hug!
Oh, she's dead again.
She's dead again.
Revive!
Revive that chat!
Revive that chat so I can hug her!
She's back!
Okay, okay, okay.
We gotta leave!
Where's the exit?
I did!
Hug me!
Go!
Don't worry.
I didn't get you!
Hey, who's she talking to?
Don't worry!
Come over here!
Hug me!
I don't care!
This isn't vois.
This is around there.
Hug me!
Help hug me!
I know.
Okay.
He's like, Beau.
He's like Beau.
I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Kiss this for the bros.
You don't kiss your bro.
If they die, you gotta kiss the bro.
You gotta kiss the homies.
Okay.
Wait,
how did you guys get up there?
I don't know.
Okay, don't worry, don't worry.
Do you need a hug too?
Okay, don't worry.
I was just hugging the homies.
I know, oh my god, there's so much jokey vert to go around, guys.
There's so much.
Alright, that was it.
I need someone to hug me.
You gotta kiss the homies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need someone to hug me.
I'm all hugged out.
Wait.
Why is it dangerous?
Because they have a dog machine.
That gun.
Dog gun.
Oh, the dog gun.
Oh, okay, okay.
Where do we go?
Where to go?
Oh my god, oh my god, we gotta leave.
We gotta leave.
Oh my god.
I
hug you, I hug you.
Come on, come on.
Give me, give me, give me.
I hug, I hug.
Go away.
I'm dying.
Guy?
Yeah?
He's gonna die.
Oh, he's gonna die.
Don't worry, I got a hug.
I got the kisses.
Oh, shit.
I don't want.
Okay, okay, okay.
Where is she?
Where's she at?
You know?
Oh my god.
I can see her.
Wait, I think she ran up.
No, she ran.
This is outside.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did Hiro die?
Oh, okay.
I think she's ran off.
Did she run away without us?
Wow, Hiro.
Hiro.
Oh, wait.
Wait, I think she is dead.
Hiro.
Wait, but she has the camera.
Yeah, she has the camera.
What do we do?
We have to go back, go back, go back.
Okay, not we have to go back.
One of us has to go back.
Okay, here's the hug.
Okay, wait, wait.
Are we all full HP?
Yeah, I'm full HP.
Okay, okay.
If we talk, it will run out so fast.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Look,
it's not my fault.
It's not my fault.
Okay?
Like, look.
I was dying from lack of oxygen.
And Hiro and Nachan is definitely dead.
Right?
I'm pretty sure Nachan is dead too.
Like, they're not moving.
But it's okay, it's okay.
Dudo is still alive.
She's still moving.
So technically she's still alive.
She's coming over?
I think?
This is 98.
Oh, it stopped at 90.
Oh, no, no, no, it's still moving.
She has 5% oxygen left, but she's still moving.
Look!
Look at the manual!
There's hearts around it.
I'm giving the homies a kiss for good luck.
Okay.
Oh, she's coming back.
Oh, wouldn't it be funny if she died with 0% oxygen?
Let me see.
Oh, she's definitely dead.
Oh, she's dead.
Oh, she is.
Wait, 26 meters?
I might be able to get the camera.
She may have died here.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, she did not get the camera.
Okay.
She did not get the camera.
Alright, goodbye.
Okay.
It's okay.
Guys!
I got the defibrillator.
Guys, I got this.
I got...
Oh, great.
It's okay, guys.
We can get the camera tomorrow.
I got this bag.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we'll get the camera tomorrow.
It's like, where did Hiro go?
Hiro, where?
Everybody missed me.
Don't go, Hiro.
It's like, don't go?
It's okay, I lived.
Alright, someone take the...
Alright, someone take the revive.
Revive and hug.
I'm all like, hugged out.
I'm all hugged out now.
I've hugged too many people.
No money.
I have flashlight.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
17%.
Good thinking.
I'm recharging.
I had almost no battery.
Don't worry.
Here you go.
I have to charge this one too.
Wait, what are you charging?
Oh, the defib.
Revive.
Alright guys.
Are you guys all ready?
Don't worry.
We're gonna film something really cool.
No worries.
We're gonna make content here.
Yeah.
This is new.
Is this new?
Yeah.
Oh.
I've never seen this.
Wee.
Alright, I got flashlight.
Wait, who has camera?
Wait, is that...
Oh, hug.
I give you the hug.
Wait, who's hugging?
Here, here, here.
Who?
Wait, I go get the other camera.
Oh, there's other cam...
Okay, okay.
Oh.
I got it, I got it.
Oh, the other camera.
Oh.
Wait, there's another one.
There's...
Put me under.
Look, look, look.
Film, film, film.
Okay, now...
Look at this.
It's so beautiful.
Wow.
This is five...
This is one Akasupa.
If you want to have this, it is one Akasupa.
It's so cheap.
Akasupa.
Are we waiting for Hiro?
Wait, wait.
Don't eat.
Wait for Hiro.
Wait for Hiro?
Okay.
Yeah, wait for Hiro.
I'm going to explore a little.
Don't worry.
I'm going to find the monster and bring it to them for content, guys.
It's going to be...
Just think about the views, chat.
Think about the...
The...
How much...
How viral we're going to get when I find the monster.
Come on.
I'm right here.
Wait, where is it?
Where did he go?
Where?
Did he blow himself up?
Where did he go?
Wait, did the monster...
Did the monster blow himself up?
Hello?
Wait.
They left me.
Hello?
I have the flashlight.
That's it.
Okay.
Where did they go?
Hello?
Ditto?
Nah, Chen!
They left me!
How could they leave me like this?
Oh no.
I have nothing.
What's that?
I can't believe it.
I would never ditch them.
That's so fucked up.
I would never do such a thing.
Hello?
Guys?
Where the fuck are they?
Wait, this is a new area.
Where the fuck is our ship though?
Oh no.
Where is our ship?
Ship is over there.
Oh my god.
It's so fucking far.
Why is...
Why is the ship so...
What do you mean I'm innocent?
I never leave anybody.
I said I was gonna bring...
I was trying to help us get content.
I was trying to help us find a monster.
Just to get us content.
But it's okay.
I know where they are.
Okay.
Let me head back to the ship and see if they're still alive.
Hello guys?
Are you guys still alive?
Are they still moving?
They're still moving.
Okay.
Okay, they're still alive.
They're very...
Oh my god, they're getting further and further away from the ship.
I have no idea where they are.
Oh my god, they're so far away.
Guys, they're so fucking far away.
How the fuck am I supposed to...
Hello?
You do not hear jack shit.
What do you mean you can still hear them?
Look at how far they are away from me.
How do you have 60% oxygen still?
Is this here?
No, that's Ditto.
Did they spend their time in the ship?
Okay.
Wait, do I lose oxygen if I...
Alright.
They're still really far away from me.
They seem to...
Yeah, they...
No, I'm pretty sure they're together.
I'm pretty sure.
They just don't have a flashlight at all.
They just...
They're definitely together.
It's just that they don't have a flashlight.
Alright.
Okay.
And they have the camera.
They're making content.
Guys?
Hello?
Are you guys still alive?
Guys?
Yeah!
Nachan!
Follow my voice!
Hello?
Where are you?
Are you here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm up here.
Oh my god!
Where did you guys go?
You're alive!
I'm here.
Yeah, yeah.
And I said, wait.
I said, wait.
And then I was...
What?
Nachan?
I said, wait.
I said, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait here.
I found a monster!
I was gonna give you guys content!
You guys got content?
Okay, okay.
Let's go downstairs.
We still have time.
Yay!
I found like a monster when you guys weren't here.
Look!
There he is!
Oh, hello!
Oh my god!
Lion King!
It's like Lion King!
Get picked up!
Get picked up for content!
Content!
Oh, good content!
Good content!
Oh, they're picking her up.
She's picking...
She...
Nachan's fucking dead.
Oh my god!
Okay, okay.
I need one.
Holy shit.
Okay, okay.
Wait.
Who am I?
Flamin'!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna die!
It's up to Hiro!
Help me!
Mokan!
It's up to Hiro!
Haku, me!
I have to natchen.
We don't have to natchen!
It's
up to me.
Leave!
Go, Garigaku!
They're dead.
Oh my god.
They don't have to hear you, the dead don't talk!
Haru, Haru, Haru!
Go, Horu, go, Horu, go!
Hanging each other.
Karaso Mom, hold him.
.
Everyone's dead.
I was waiting for a monster to come in and just hit them.
I got picked up.
I laughed at Nachan.
I laughed at Nachan getting picked up by the monster and then I got picked up.
And when you got picked up, they told... he told you to me.
I thought it was so funny and then I died.
Do we have enough film?
Because I can dance.
I can dance too.
Oh, no film.
Okay.
Alright, we need money.
We have zero views.
We need money.
She has it.
Nice.
We're doing it.
Okay.
I got it.
Let's watch.
I'll first.
The first CD.
Okay.
Film, film, film.
Look at this.
It's so beautiful.
Wow.
So beautiful.
This is one Akasupa.
If you want to watch this, it's one Akasupa.
This is Doggy Spawn.
What the f**k?
Doggy, Doggy.
Doggy.
This is the second day, I think.
Yeah, this is today.
This is today.
I say, I say, wait for here.
Hello.
Oh, this one is the...
Oh my god.
35k views.
Look at all the views.
Oh my god.
I should dance.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
It's okay, we're still alive.
You don't have to cry anymore.
Oh my god, $400!
We got $400!
Whoa!
Okay, next one next.
Backflip!
Ooh!
What's this?
What is that?
Mojio is very clumsy.
Doggy!
This is me!
Everything is still me.
Everything is me.
Oh, is this where he died?
Is this where he died?
This is where he died.
Look at the view!
Look at that!
It's because Hiro died!
He died!
Hiro died so then we got so much views!
Oh my god, we're doing so well guys.
I always believed in us.
Now I'm happy again.
Look at that.
Now I'm happy.
Damn!
We're so fucking good at this.
Hiro died so the channel can live.
She died for our sins guys.
She died for our sins.
Now I'm happy now because we're making money.
Yeah, we have $1000!
Oh my god!
Guys, guys, guys, guys.
Guys, guys.
Emoto, Emoto, Emoto.
This is it.
We saved for this.
Guys, this is it.
We saved for this emote.
And I think Nachan should have it.
Nachan, you should have this.
Wait, wait, Nachan, Nachan, Nachan.
Take this.
Wow!
Thank you!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, use it.
Yeah.
E.
T, T, T, T.
T.
T, T, T,
T, T, T, T, T.
Yes!
Go!
T, T, T, T.
T, T, T, T, T.
T, T, T, T, T, T, T.
Oh my god, you're so cool Nachan.
You're so cool.
$500.
Should we get something else?
Do we need a flashlight?
I want a flashlight!
Do you want to try one long flashlight?
Yeah, we should try one.
Do we have enough?
We don't have enough.
We don't have enough for a long flashlight.
Oh wait, we do!
Oh, flash this one.
Yeah, we can get it.
What's this?
Guys, I have a flare.
Emergency only.
Flash.
Alright, did you buy the flashlight?
Yeah, and I'm gonna buy us one good...
Good ball.
Alright.
Wow!
Wow, who taught you that?
Hiro, what did you teach her?
She's so mean!
She's saying that to me!
Hiro, teach her.
It's so long.
Are you good to go?
Alright.
Yeah, okay.
It's alright.
We already did it.
We already made money.
Nana-chan, Nana-chan, do you have flashlight?
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay, I will give you here.
Just this one.
Okay.
Okay,
I'll defib.
Okay, I'll defib.
Do you guys trust me?
I got flashlight.
You all trust me.
Right?
You guys all trust me, right?
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh, you recharged it.
Okay.
Alright.
I believe in your content.
Wait, where?
Oh, hey, there's already Torbjorn!
For an Akasupa!
Alright, so now this is...
This is two Akasupas now.
We're more famous.
So we can charge more.
So this is two Akasupas.
Oh, okay.
Like and subscribe.
Supply and demand!
We're famous now!
We can charge more!
Supply and demand!
Okay.
Down we go!
Wee!
Here we go!
Okay.
Alright.
We need to find new monsters!
Oh, there's a skull here!
A skull!
Yeah, skull.
Laser!
There's a laser?
Can we walk through it?
Oh, I don't think we can.
Wait, wait.
I think I can.
Watch this.
Guys, guys.
Watch this, guys.
Okay, wait.
Someone picked this up.
Okay, watch this, guys.
Watch.
Okay, film me, film me, film me.
Okay.
I'm not filming.
Filming?
Are you filming?
Okay.
Oh!
That's right.
Wow!
That's terrible.
I'm trying to get the punch back.
What?
She's stuck!
Oh, shit!
Oh!
What?
Oh, no!
Oh, she's coming!
She's coming!
I only got the defense!
I think she has the hug, too!
No, no, no, no, no!
Okay.
We're fine.
Walk around.
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
Oh, God.
Is she at the hug?
Oh, no, she didn't.
Is she okay?
Are you okay?
Nacha, are you okay?
I got you!
You're okay!
I saved you!
Okay.
Where's Ditto?
Ditto, are you alive?
Okay.
We only have one revive.
We did it.
Okay.
Let's go to...
I took the flame.
Yeah.
I flamed the dog.
Okay.
Let's go.
Let's find the other...
There's another exit, right?
Another entrance.
Let's go to the other one.
He ero died for content.
She, she died for content.
Like you...
I tried to backflip over.
Yeah.
Try.
You tried.
Definitely.
Oh, oh, oh, slime.
Slime?
He ero, he ero, he ero!
Yeah.
Go to the slime, he ero.
Go!
Goodbye Hiro!
Goodbye!
Maybe she's still here.
Guys, I don't think Hiro's alive anymore.
Are we gonna leave?
Hiro?
Where is Hiro's body?
She got kidnapped.
Yeah, she got kidnapped.
Oh, Hiro!
Oh, there she is!
Oh my god!
What's your HP?
She did it!
Hiro's alive!
We're gonna go back to our basement, guys.
We should see if there's a big monster.
I'm pretty sure a big monster might show up.
Let's go to the other entrance.
I'm not out of the frame.
Oh, where are you guys?
I hear something.
I hear the slime.
Hug?
Oh yeah, hug.
Hug.
Hug time.
I have 0% 0%?
Okay, okay.
Let's go home then.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Home time.
Let's go home first.
Oh, goodbye.
Guys, I don't think...
Guys, Hiro got kidnapped.
Not Chad.
Where's Hiro?
Hiro?
Is Hiro dead?
Maybe.
Did she die?
I think maybe she should go back.
Oh!
I think Ditto's dead.
Mine!
Ditto?
Oh, Ditto's alive!
Ditto's alive!
There she is!
Oh, Hiro's alive!
You need a hug?
I need a hug from my mentor.
Help.
Okay.
I'll watch.
I'm gonna watch.
That's right!
That's crazy!
Alright, okay, Ki.
Let's go home.
No one's dead!
Hiro's still alive!
She's still alive!
She did it!
I always believed in you, Hiro.
I knew you would never die.
Dengue bug dying!
Yeah, Hiro never... Hiro's never die.
Hiro's never die!
Yes, yes, Ditto.
Overwatch 2 is gonna be free soon.
What an end.
We should have recorded that.
That was such a good line to end on.
Are we gonna stay the video?
We should sack it.
We have so much... so many views.
Sack it, sack it.
Oh yeah!
Alright.
We end this collab when we die.
Okay?
When we all die?
When we all die.
We end... When we lose our channel, we all end collab.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
This collab doesn't stop until our channel dies.
Just like real streaming.
Real streaming.
Okay, okay, okay.
Good night.
Good night everybody.
So fast.
Oh my god.
325k.
That's a lot.
We can watch it now, right?
Yeah, we could.
I don't know.
I think we should film the next one and then watch it.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
We can watch it now.
Yeah, watch it later.
I feel like we should watch it later and then watch both of them at the same time.
Alright.
No money time.
Wait, what's this?
No money.
Oh, it's the old party poppy.
I'm gonna buy one old flashlight.
Okay, I'm gonna buy... I'm gonna buy this too.
No money.
My order too.
Money order.
Party poppy.
Whenever somebody dies, I'll pop this.
Okay.
I'm looking.
Can I die from this?
Guys, guys, guys!
Whoa!
What?
Guys, guys, guys!
Someone!
Guys!
No, no, no!
No, no,
no!
Oh, I live though.
You're laughing!
Why?
I have this though.
What?
Did you film the...
Oh my god.
Did you film it?
I think she filmed you.
Did you at least film it?
But I lived!
I lived though.
Aren't you all happy that I lived?
Damn.
We can't...
We can't live like this.
We have money.
We have our $300 revolver.
We have $300.
Don't you guys...
Guys, but I'm alive!
Guys, I'm alive too!
Nice.
Wait, is there any holes here?
No holes.
Oh, head, head, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, I can't... woah, this makes it scarier.
I can't turn this off, by the way.
Guys, I can't turn this off, so we're gonna use it forever.
Wait, why is there light?
Did you guys see that?
There was a light over there.
Yeah.
Over here.
Oh, it's the bar.
Run!
The ants are killed!
Wait.
Yeah?
Did you film it?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, it's the half camera.
Wait, you don't have the camera?
Yeah.
Wait, who is it?
Who got the camera?
Maybe here or not.
Okay, okay, I'm gonna go downstairs and I'm gonna try and get it.
What?
Can you hear me?
I don't have ears!
I have ears!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
We're gonna get one punch.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're still gonna die regardless!
Are you at full HP?
Not yet.
Okay, full.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna grab the camera.
Remember, Dino, remember.
Okay, my flare ran out.
Remember me, Dino!
Remember me!
First camera.
I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Film this, film this.
Dino, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Film this.
Wait, wait, no.
Which one?
First camera, first camera.
Where did I throw the other thing?
Wait, did you take the other thing I got?
Okay, okay.
I'm filming.
Oh, film me, film me, film me, film me, film me.
Are you filming?
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Alright, we don't have, we don't have a rewind.
No, we don't!
No, I don't.
We gotta go.
Guys.
Okay.
Why, why, that's two.
Why, that's not two.
Okay.
How much more film?
Wait, how much film do we have left?
Dino.
Um, 63.
Okay, stay here, stay here.
Okay, listen.
Stay here and we film.
We film.
Okay?
Okay, film.
Okay, okay.
Hello, guys.
Um, we lost two people.
But it was so cool, though.
It was so funny.
Okay, stop the film.
I got an idea, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
Stop the film.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm gonna do something stupid.
Okay, watch this.
Okay, stay in here.
Stay in here.
Okay?
Uh-huh.
Alright.
Okay, this flashlight is more expensive.
I'm gonna keep, I'm gonna keep this.
Okay.
Wait.
Let me throw away the...
Okay, there.
Alright, stay in here.
I'm gonna bring them to me.
Okay, I'm gonna bring them to me.
Close the door.
When I say close the door, close the door.
Okay.
I'm gonna be a hero.
I'm gonna be a hero for content.
I'm so good at content.
Okay, he was right here.
There's no...
Okay, I'm gonna go back.
Does anyone know where he is?
Is he coming over?
Is he?
Is that him?
Oh!
Open it!
Open it up!
Found!
Oh my god!
What are you doing?
Why did you run at it?
Mommy!
We got the content!
We got it!
He punched you!
And you just died!
Oh my god!
That's so scary!
That was so scary!
Oh wait, we don't have the...
Oh my god!
That was so scary!
We're gonna pay you!
Alright, here we go.
Thank you!
Oh, it's this one?
Yeah.
E.
T.
Who are you?
What the fuck?
What a lovely gesture!
Oh wait, there's already Chorby!
One Akasupa!
Akasupa!
This is two Akasupas now.
We're more famous.
So we can charge more.
This is two Akasupas.
Yes, go.
Guys, watch.
Okay, film me, film me, film me.
Film me.
Are you filming?
Yeah.
Woah!
Yes!
What?
Good job, Hiro.
Oh my god, 76, 77 views!
79!
It's going higher!
Okay, okay!
Okay!
Go, go, go!
Goodbye, Hiro.
It's a H T!
She did it!
Hiro is still alive!
We're the best JoJo basemates, guys.
Nice.
90!
You got 90 views!
Okay, the next one.
Okay.
Alright, I think this one will be pretty good.
If somebody dies, I'll pop this.
Oh my god!
I'm the king!
Yay.
There was a light over there.
What you think I got?
Okay, okay.
I'm filming.
Film me, film me, film me, film me.
Are you filming?
We lost two people.
But it was so cool though.
It was so funny.
Okay, stop the film.
I got an idea.
Alright, okay.
This flashlight is more expensive.
I'm gonna keep this.
Okay.
Wait, let me throw away the...
Okay, there.
Alright, stay here.
I'm gonna bring them to me.
Okay, I'm gonna bring them to me.
Close the door.
Why do I have to close the door?
Okay.
What?
Oh my god!
Wait, that's all you got?
That's all you got?
I'm the monster?
I don't know.
I have to run away.
What the f***?
Film me!
I'm flaming.
Oh my god.
That's all you got.
I have to leave now.
What the f***?
We did it.
Come on, film her.
Okay, Nachan.
Yeah, Nachan, you be the film.
Okay, we got it.
Let's buy the deep river.
Wait, we need the revive.
Yeah, we need the revive.
Okay, okay, okay.
Don't worry, I got the revive.
Nachan, you need to get this.
You have to destroy it.
Okay, okay, okay.
I can't believe it.
I got one second of content from that.
I can't believe it did it.
Ditto, Ditto screamed at the end.
I led the f***ing guy over and Ditto only filled one second.
I can't believe it, Ditto.
I risked my life for that guy.
No!
We closed the door.
No, no, no.
It's not my fault.
You closed the door.
We would have...
Whoa!
We closed the door.
What is this?
Oh, this is scary.
I've never seen this before.
Maybe this is new?
Yeah, this has to be new, right?
No, no, no.
It's in the middle.
Oh, it's over here.
Oh.
Let's do it.
I'm not scared.
This is for the...
Woo!
Oh, it's the baker.
It's the baker.
Film it, film it, film it.
Guys, guys, guys, watch out.
Guys, guys, guys.
I might be dead.
Guys, okay.
Okay, okay.
Watch.
Guys, I can't get to you.
I need hugs, guys.
I need hugs.
Oh my god.
What the f***?
Hug me.
Okay, okay.
Hug all of us.
Wait,
is Hiro dead?
Oh my god.
Hiro, ball, shit.
Last one, last one.
Eh, eh, dammit.
Hug me, hug me, hug me.
I can't hug me.
I can't hug you.
I have it, I have it, I have it.
Hug, hug, hug, hug.
Oh my god.
We're all hugged.
Wait, Nacha, Nacha.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
Are we all fully?
Okay, I need hugs.
I need hugs.
Nacha's dead.
Can someone hug me?
Guys, I think we hugged too much.
Yeah, yeah, I need a hug.
I don't have, I don't have.
Okay, I can hug.
Okay, okay.
Alright.
Okay, I'm good, I'm good.
Alright, we don't have any more batteries for the defib.
Alright, goodbye.
Wait, wait, wait.
We should film the dead body.
Did we film the dead body?
Yeah, I did.
I did.
Okay, nice, nice.
Good content.
Okay, okay, can I do a pretend?
Pretend defib?
Okay, are you ready?
Are you filming?
Don't you die on me, Nacha!
She's dead.
Okay.
Alright,
we're good.
We need to find more monsters.
Wait, there's something here.
Oh, yeah, yeah, no, no.
I see eyes.
Who's stuck?
Where are you?
Daniel, do you have the hugs?
Wait, did you...
Oh, she's coming!
The bus is coming!
Oh!
I don't have flashlight anymore.
Daniel, are you alive?
I'm still alive, but I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Do you have the hugs?
Wait, yours have a hug.
I'm stuck too!
Oh, I'm good.
I'm good.
Jump, jump, jump, jump.
Space box, space box.
I'm gonna die!
Oh my gosh!
Oh, I kicked it out!
Spider with me!
I'm trying, I'm trying to get out of here.
We're slowly watching.
Film this!
Film this, hero!
Film her dying!
Film it!
Give me my flashlight!
Take my flashlight!
Hero, leave!
Leave!
Just go home!
Go home!
I
have a flashlight here.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got it.
Do you need hugs?
No.
How much film do you have left?
This is not our home!
We can find it!
We'll walk around!
Wait, I think it's the cars.
How much film do you have left?
31%.
Okay, we go around.
I'm pretty sure we can go around here though.
Really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I believe.
It has to be like here somewhere.
Oh no.
I don't think so.
I think we need to go.
Woo!
Okay.
Alright.
We split up!
Hero!
Oh no.
Down is up.
You're so good at that.
Oh no.
I can't hug myself.
It's so over.
I don't know where to go.
Where do we go?
Down is not up.
Oh!
Hero!
He's still alive!
I don't...
Oh my god.
Hero!
Holy shit.
How do we get home?
How the fuck do we get home?
There's a little screamy guy!
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Where is home?
What?
Oh god.
Oh!
Hero!
You know what?
We're so smart!
Oh my god!
The spider followed me all the way to the ship.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, wait.
Wait.
We stay here.
How much film do you have left?
I have 18%.
Okay.
I'm gonna hug you.
We're gonna...
I'm gonna leave them... Okay.
Okay.
You hug me.
And then like we're gonna... I'm gonna...
Can you hug me?
And then I'm gonna do it for content.
How much person?
I have 16.
Okay.
Are you ready to film?
Please film more than Ditto.
Okay.
I'm gonna drop the flashlight.
Alright.
Here we go.
Hello.
I'm gonna... I'll do this for content.
Where are the monsters?
Oh, now all the monsters stop fucking trying to kill me.
Oh, wow.
The one time.
Hello?
I hear him.
I'm right here.
Oh!
Oh, I messed up!
No!
Guys,
I didn't mean it.
It's over.
I don't think she...
She's dead?
She's dead.
I'm dead.
It's okay.
I threw everything away.
I threw everything.
I sacrificed myself for content.
For content.
Oh my god.
I saw all of them.
I saw...
Look, I... He hit me into the fucking tongue.
He hit me into the fucking tongue.
Wait, parkour.
I got the tongue.
I got tongued.
I died for content.
Nice.
Alright, let's check how many views we get.
How many views did we get?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
We're watching time.
No, no, no, no, no.
Guys, guys, guys.
Watch this.
I need hugs, guys.
I need hugs.
Okay.
Are you filming?
Don't you dare be that chance.
That spider.
That spider was so scary.
Yeah.
Don't have flashlights on.
Hey.
Oh my
god.
You're gonna jump something.
Filming, filming, filming.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I can't get all of that.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you know.
That's such good filming.
Oh my god.
200.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
We did it.
That was great.
I feel like Hiro has been the best filmer.
Of all of us.
She's peak cinema.
Actually movie director.
Vlog.
What's this?
She's gonna be the new Paul brothers.
Yeah.
The spider gave us a lot.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
She's the best film director.
From all of us.
Actually a good film.
Can we ever lose?
We're so good at this game.
We're never gonna lose.
We can get a million views.
I feel like we can.
Yeah.
We have... how much money?
We have like 900 dollars.
Is there anything else we should get?
I think...
Okay, I need another flashlight.
Or another defib.
Or hugger.
Wait, who has the hugger and defib?
Me.
I have hugger.
I have revive.
I don't think we need like...
more than one.
I just need a flashlight.
That's all I need.
Do we need...
the revive?
One more?
No, I think we're fine.
I think hugging is much more important than defib.
Right?
Yeah.
We gotta save the homie with the hugs.
Wait, we should get taser.
Wait, wait, wait.
How much money do we have?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll be DPS.
Okay.
You gotta film this though.
Watch.
Wow!
What is this?
Okay, wait, wait.
Who's filming?
Where's the film?
Wait, it's in the ground.
Wait, who's filming?
I have it.
Okay, are you ready?
Are you filming?
Yeah, I'm filming.
Okay, watch this.
What?
Why me?
Fuck you!
You said you wanted to know.
Do it again!
Okay, you do it again.
You wanted to know what it was.
Why me?
Are you ready?
Last day.
Should we get the emote?
What should we get?
Flashlight?
Or emote.
We all have an emote.
I have only one emote.
We can all only have one emote.
We can't like overlap it.
Yeah.
Are you all ready?
Let's go.
Yoga.
Oh, yoga.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see.
What is her emote?
I wanna see.
We need to emote on the monsters.
Oh, true, true.
Oh, when I zap them, we emote.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, let's get it.
Let's go.
We got this.
Okay.
Yeah.
We gotta get our first million views.
What?
What is that?
Oh.
Oh!
Film, film, film, film, film, film, film!
Oh, he's falling!
He fell!
He's dead.
He's...
He's... He's a gay dead.
He's a gay dead.
Come on.
I can't...
Nice.
Look at us.
We're so good.
Rest in peace, spider.
Okay, we gotta find somebody I can zap.
I'm so scared.
It's him!
Oh,
he's not...
Take a picture!
No, film!
Film him!
Wait, you have to be okay!
Okay!
I have no more zap!
I'm... I'm hugging...
I don't think...
I'm hugging the monster!
I can hug you!
Goodbye now, Chad.
Can you hug me?
Yeah, yeah.
Where is it?
Hug me!
You guys hug each other!
Yeah!
Okay!
Oh!
Wait!
Hug!
Oh, that's nice!
I can hug while being hugged.
I feel like...
Yeah, you should be... Hug me!
Okay.
We're okay.
Hug me!
I have 50%!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Let's go!
Yeah, yeah.
I can hug while being hugged.
Guys, I don't have a zap anymore.
What?
He's scared!
Just run!
I'm fine!
Are you sure?
Are you sure you're fine?
I'm not gonna die!
Are you sure?
He's on me!
Hug me!
He's looking!
He's coming back!
Oh, no!
Run!
Are they still hugging?
Are they still...
Are they okay?
I'm not okay!
Someone hug me, please!
Hug each other!
Stop!
Alright, let's go downstairs!
Let's go downstairs!
We need more content!
Let's go this way!
Guys, O is here!
Yeah, but he's not here though.
So we should be fine, right?
See?
Oh...
I'm lost here.
That's a lot!
We have two hugger, that's a lot!
That's so good!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Two hugs is actually really good.
Wait!
I'm lost!
Oh!
I found the way!
Right here!
Wait, what is here?
Oh, it's death.
Wait, can I land here?
Can I land there?
Guys, guys, guys!
Guys, guys, come over here!
Come, guys, guys!
Hello?
Guys, watch this.
Okay, guys.
If this works, it's gonna be so fucking cool.
Okay, I shouldn't.
Hahaha!
Hello?
Hello, guys?
They're dead?
Revive-
Oh no.
I know who killed them.
I know who killed them!
Oh my god.
Did you revive them?
They're right behind me!
He's right behind me!
Oh, are you guys okay?
Okay, okay, okay, wait, wait.
Oh.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
No, no, no, no!
Guys, guys, guys!
Guys, guys, guys, guys, guys!
Guys, I have the camera!
I HAVE THE CAMERA!
I have the camera!
Don't let him do this to me!
Come here, come here!
I have two on two!
No!
Can you hug?
There's two of them.
Guys, I need the hug too!
I need the hug!
I'm good, I'm good.
I'm right here!
I'm right behind you guys!
Okay.
Hug me, hug me, hug me.
If you hug me, I can film.
I can film them if he comes over.
Oh, fuck, fuck!
Okay, okay.
I have a cool film idea.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
The killer, the killer!
Here.
Careful, careful, careful.
Oh god.
There's a... there's an explosion!
There's an explosion!
Oh.
Oh!
Okay.
We're fine, we're fine.
We're not fine, we're not fine, we're not fine, we're not fine.
We're not fine.
Is he still there?
He's still there!
Okay.
Ditto, are you alive, Ditto?
I don't think...
Wait, I'm gonna check, I'm gonna check the distance.
Let's see.
Yeah, no, they're dead.
They're definitely dead.
Come inside!
You're gonna film him?
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, I'm gonna film.
Drop your stuff, drop your stuff down there.
Okay.
Where is he?
He's right in front of us.
I think he left.
Okay, okay, you wanna film something really cool?
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'm gonna throw away stuff.
And then we're gonna film something really cool.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, okay, okay.
Pick up the camera.
Oh.
Okay.
What?
I think we left her to dead too.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
Film something really sick.
Alright, follow me, follow me.
Follow me, follow me, follow me.
Pick up the camera.
Okay, I know where to go.
Follow me.
This is gonna be so cool.
Okay.
Don't worry, I know exactly where to go.
It's gonna be so cool.
Wait.
It's okay, they're not close.
They're not close.
Alright, right here.
They are close!
Wait,
I lost.
Goodbye!
Close door, close door, close door, close door, close door, close door, close door!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, are you okay?
Are you okay?
Oh, god.
We're gonna be okay.
Okay.
Alright.
I couldn't find the cool thing.
It was gonna be like parkour.
I was gonna parkour.
Hahaha.
He was like so close.
He was so close.
I wanted to parkour.
There's a defib and a flashlight inside.
There's a defib and a flashlight in the ship.
Follow me.
I'm gonna charge my...
No, I couldn't do my parkour.
It was gonna be so cool.
Hahaha.
Alright.
I'm charging my thing.
Nice.
Oh yeah, who wants the hug?
I dropped the hug.
Anyone wants it?
Maybe we have to buy one more hug.
Hahaha.
You need one more?
Okay, I'll buy one more.
I lost one.
Oh, we lost one?
Okay, yeah.
We need another hug.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
She is so cute.
It's so long.
Video.
Nice.
Alright, I got it.
We should save it.
We already have the views.
Yeah, we should save it.
Alright.
Yeah, cause we're...
We're two good content creators.
We're just so good.
You guys are so good.
I know, we're so good at this.
I'm so inspired.
Now I'm so happy.
I wanna get one million... one million views.
Oh my god.
644.
Holy shit.
A lot.
644.
Is the next one one million?
Yeah, I think next one is one million.
Yeah.
Okay.
Nachan is gonna film today.
Alright.
I believe in Nachan.
We only have one hug.
We have revive and hot hug.
Where's my flashlight?
We don't have money though.
Do we?
Do we have money for a hug?
Where's my other flashlight?
I have flashlight.
Okay.
Wait.
Is Hiro okay?
Guys, I think Hiro crashed.
Hiro?
Oh!
Guys, I think Hiro crashed.
I guess.
He didn't crash.
Oh!
Hiro crashed!
Oh my god.
Hiro crashed.
Goodbye Hiro.
Hiro...
Oh no, you know what?
I think i think she crashed.
I think she crashed.
You guys, are you all.
I invited you guys.
Oh, wait, did we start that?
No, you couldn't.
Sorry, I forgot it's muted on Discord.
No, we were like, where did Hiro go?
Sorry.
Can you invite Diddle?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me join off of you.
Where the fuck are you?
Can we continue?
Are we still in the same area?
Same level?
Yes, yes, yes, same.
Okay, okay.
I didn't receive the invite.
You sent the invite again?
Oh, no.
I don't have the invite.
Oh, I got it.
I'm just telling you.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got it, I got it.
I'll invite Nachan again too.
Okay.
Oh, it's still the same.
It's still the same.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's the same.
Totally the same.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
It's the same.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was gonna be like, no.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
We're okay.
We're okay, guys.
We didn't lose.
Oh, I'm the same.
I'm the same.
We didn't lose.
You guys...
Wait, did we lose our items?
Maybe we lost our items.
We lost our items.
Nachan.
No, I got one of the...
I got the flashlight.
I don't have the shinko.
Okay, where is she?
Riding.
Riding?
Okay.
Where are the other items?
No.
I lost the shock sticks.
Wait, did we actually lose the items?
Yeah, we lost the items.
Oh, it's here.
It's here.
We have the disc here.
Oh, no, no.
Mina, everyone, here, here, here.
I take you here.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice one, nice one.
Okay, okay.
Oh, my God.
My emote is still here, too.
How to dance.
I can still dance.
Are you ready?
All right, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Wait, hug her, hug her.
Wait, there's a hugger.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got the hugger.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
I'm stuck.
Oh, no.
Guys.
Oh, I got out.
I got out.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I'm okay.
Can we afford a hug?
You want to buy another hugger?
Yeah, you can buy another hugger.
Okay, I bought it.
I bought it.
Okay.
I have the shot stick.
Oh, yeah.
Let me have the shot stick.
I'm gonna shot you every time.
No.
Every...
Maybe...
Every minute I was naked.
I was shaking.
No.
That's not fair.
Alright, let's go.
Film.
Film time.
No.
Need to go.
Film time.
Yeah.
I'm doing good.
1 million views.
We got this.
I believe.
1 million views.
Let's go.
I believe in us.
We can do it.
We're so good at content!
Wait, is this new?
Woah!
Yeah, this is a weird area.
Oh, it's here!
Oh, it's this area!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Jump jump time!
Jump!
Yeah!
Oh, there's animal statues!
Look, look, look!
Look, this is Ditto.
Look
at her!
What is so funny?
Film it, film it, film it!
That's the wrong one!
No, who has the D-Fim?
Give me the D-Fim!
I can't drop the D-Fim!
Are you alright?
No!
Why did I laugh?
We died.
I'm flying!
We're all sick!
Oh, no!
We're looking at the camera.
It's okay, I think we have the camera.
We have the camera.
Oh, really?
Oh my god.
We can get one.
That one is a curse.
If someone is 14, you have to give them a bunny one.
No, it was the duck.
It was the duck that...
I got the bunny, but...
No, it was the duck statue.
I don't know why.
You picked the wrong statue.
It was the duck statue that...
I see now!
The bunny was the curse.
We don't have money.
Oh, this is the other video.
We have one.
Okay, okay, okay.
We need money.
Yeah.
Insert it.
I can't insert it.
Wait, what?
Let's try.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, fuck.
No.
Take our video.
No!
Okay, maybe next day.
Okay, maybe.
Next day.
Okay, put it here.
Who has it?
Oh, I do.
My hand is stuck.
Okay, there you go.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm stuck.
Okay, there you go.
I got it.
Oh, I got it.
Oh, but that was converted a while ago.
Right?
That one was converted a while ago.
No, that was converted yesterday.
It's because you crashed.
I don't think it was...
It saved the crash at Slayers.
Oh, I know.
Oh, someone said the crash could erase it.
No!
Did it actually?
Oh, the crash erased...
Oh, it's offline.
It's offline.
Yeah, you can't see it now.
Okay, let's get the video camera.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god, we have nothing.
It's okay.
We'll check again.
We'll check again later.
We just need a big monster.
A big monster and then we'll be famous.
Can I... Can I...
Yeah, big monster.
Gotcha!
Yes.
Okay.
Film a good video.
Oh, it's here.
Ganbatte!
What?
Is it here?
We can get it back.
Yeah.
Hey, it didn't spawn.
I believe in us.
We can do it.
It's not too far.
How do you know where the camera is?
You know?
It's landing here, right?
Oh!
It's landing here.
We should have died here, right?
It's landing.
I think it's landing.
Eh?
It's not here.
Where did she die?
I died like here.
But it would light up.
It would show the camera.
I think it's the other exit.
Yeah, maybe it's in the other exit.
Let's just explore.
Explore time!
Let's go.
We need to find big monsters.
Nan-chan!
Hi!
Where's Nan-chan?
Nan -chan is here.
We need to wait for Hiro.
I was like, what do you mean?
She's here.
Wrong cat.
I couldn't see the face.
Alright.
There's no monsters.
Oh!
The tongue!
Goodbye!
Give us camera!
If you die, give us camera!
Alright.
Oh, that's me.
Look at her.
Throw the camera!
Oh!
Did she...
Ah!
Oh, shit!
Oh, no!
I was throwing the camera!
Nice!
We did it!
Laser!
We go this way.
Here.
Do you have to hold?
Okay!
Hiro, where are you?
Wow!
Scary!
So scared.
Yeah, how come now there's no monster?
Oh!
What monster is that?
Oh, it's a sabi ghost!
It's a sabi ghost!
We don't have hugs!
She's dead!
This way!
Oh, no!
Not this way!
No!
Why you follow me?
Oh, no!
It's okay.
I'll find a monster.
I'm gonna find the other camera.
I'm gonna be a Hiro.
I'm gonna be the Hiro.
What goes down must come up.
I'm gonna be the Hiro, guys.
F- Oh!
What's that sound?
Did you guys hear that?
Did you guys hear that sound?
What was that?
What the fuck was that?
What was that sound?
You guys heard that, right?
It was like...
Where could the fucking...
Oh my god.
Maybe it's over there.
Maybe the camera's over there.
I'm gonna be Hiro.
I'm gonna find the camera.
This is it.
They all laughed at me.
But I'm gonna be Hiro.
I'm gonna check if they're still alive though.
Oh, they're all dead.
Guys, now we have two cameras.
That's amazing.
I think we're...
We're pretty dead.
Maybe the camera's here.
The camera has to be...
I'm not gonna be able to find the other camera.
Okay.
The other camera has to be down here.
There's no other way.
Hello?
The fuck is that sound?
I hate it.
I hate that sound.
Where's the other camera?
I
don't like this.
I can't find the other camera.
Oh.
Where could the other camera be?
If I escape, we have two missing cameras.
Okay.
Let me double check.
No, no, no.
They're still alive.
She's still alive.
What is that sound?
Look, look, look.
58.
What is that sound?
She's alive.
I'm gonna watch this.
58.
57.
She's getting closer.
Why is she just going back and forth?
I don't like this.
Oh no.
Zeno.
Zeno!
Listen to my voice!
Why is she stuck between 59 and 58?
She stopped moving.
Ah!
What the?
What the fuck?
What was that?
What the fuck was that?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
And they died.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna get the views.
Oh my god.
We gotta get the content tomorrow.
What happened?
Did you die?
No!
I was with Hyl and she died and I took the camera.
No?
I was trying to get home.
Oh my god.
We need to have a really good content.
We need to get the camera tomorrow.
We need to find two cameras.
I don't think we can play the CD because of the crash.
It's okay.
The last two days will have so much content.
I believe in us.
I believe in the last two days.
Guys.
Last day.
We're gonna find the cameras.
Okay, we'll find the cameras.
Yeah.
Remember, right?
You died.
Okay.
Ready?
I think the day before is camera.
No!
It's okay.
The last camera, we got...
I believe.
If Nachan believes in us, I believe.
Nachan believes.
Somi believes.
Alright, let's go.
We can email when we're home.
We email when we're back home.
When we're back home, we emote.
Nino, where's the camera?
The camera is right...
Okay.
Oh, the back flip.
Emote.
Emote, views.
Oh, oh, oh.
There's Gary.
It's Gary.
Okay, okay, go, go, go.
Wow, wow, baby.
Look at the baby.
Nice, nice.
The baby doesn't hurt, so you're fine.
I'm trying to find the camera too.
I found bone.
Alright, we should film other stuff too.
Um, doggie?
Yeah.
Um, um...
No, I mean this orb.
Oh, oh, wait, wait, where did it go?
What happened?
It disappeared in the light.
No, where did Nachan go?
He disappeared in the light.
Nachan and Ditto go.
They're dead.
What happened?
What?
I'm gonna try and capture their body.
Hey, pause, pause.
Pause, pause, pause.
Oh, no!
Whoa!
Wait, I can't jump.
Oh, I'm coming!
What the fuck?
He touched me!
Oh my god!
What the...
What?
What happened?
It's okay.
Maybe you'll go down.
I'll go back up.
Down is up.
The ghost parkour.
Okay, I found another...
I guess I'll just die forever.
I hope so.
I hope Hiro...
Goodbye.
fucking does this for us.
Fucking does this for us.
Goodbye.
Is that it or not?
Is that it?
Wait, I...
Are we all dead?
Doki Doki, we got a ride to the help pit.
Our
careers...
No!
Oh my gosh.
We didn't even win Viall.
Shame!
Oh, thank god.
It was just a bad dream.
Okay, we're still alive.
Oh, GG's.
GG's, everybody.
GG's.
I had a lot of fun.
Yeah, woo!
GG's, guys.
That was so fun!
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, do you guys know?
Wait, you guys are all good at Apex too, right?
Cause Ditto's also Apex Pred.
Yeah!
We're like...
We're all... we're all...
We're all Apex gamers.
Wait, you two also play Apex?
Yeah, yeah.
Four of us.
All four.
Really?
Yeah, they're masters.
Let's play next time.
Yeah, I'll stream snipe you guys.
We've fought it.
Yeah, yeah, I'll stream snipe.
Oh yeah!
No, we are not scared of Doki because she's noob.
What?
That's fucked up.
I'm gonna kill you.
Yeah.
I'm waiting for you to stream snipe, okay?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
You three queue together.
If you snipe me, I will kill you.
Okay, okay, you three queue together.
I'll stream snipe you guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm a cute skater.
Okay, okay, I'll kill all of you.
I'm waiting for you to snipe.
GG's, guys.
I had lots of fun.
GG's.
Our end of stream.
Bye bye, guys.
I'm gonna talk to my chat.
Thank you for joining.
Thank you, guys.
Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you guys.
Nice to meet you, Nachan.
Nice to meet you.
Yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'll kill you guys in Apex.
Okay?
Okay.
Okay, bye bye.
Bye bye.
Bye.
Oh, wait.
Okay, that was...
That was fun.
Let me swap real fast.
That was... Oh, I had a great time.
I had a great time playing with Ditto, Hiro, and Nachan.
It was great.
I hope you guys had a fun time meeting Hiro and Nachan.
I'm really happy to be able to collab with them.
It was so fun playing Content Warning for the first time.
I can't believe we all...
I can't believe I was the last hope and I got fucking sucked up by the fucking tongue.
But, oh my god, it's been three hours.
I didn't realize we've been playing Content Warning for three hours now.
Um...
Um... But yeah, bro.
Content Warning has to be so hard to audio balance.
I didn't realize how hard it was to audio balance Content Warning.
It was such a...
Uh... It was so...
Like, the echo.
I wish you could like, turn down the echo.
I can't believe it.
You can't turn down the echo for that.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
But it was still really, really, really fun.
I hope your ears are okay, chat.
I hope your ears are okay.
Cause that was...
That was a lot of screaming.
Um...
But, thank you all for joining.
Um, it was amazing playing with Jiro, Nachan, and Hiro.
I really enjoyed my time with them.
Um, I wanted to...
I'm so tired.
I'm so tired from laughing, um, and screaming, and everything.
But it was, uh, a great time.
And... Oh, you guys have had a fun time too.
Uh, meeting them for the first time.
Um, my brain is fried right now, so I can't form sentences properly.
My brain is so fried.
Oh, oh!
A little update!
A little update.
Uh, I think I was talking to like the Minecraft people.
Um, but basically next week, um, we might have the dragoons members Minecraft server.
So, they said like around...
It would be like around next week or like a little bit after next week.
So, I'm super, super excited, um, to have the Minecraft server soon.
Uh, for you dragoons.
Um, it's gonna be members only, but I'll be streaming the server itself public because of the rules.
You know?
The Minecraft rules.
Um...
It says that, uh, you can like...
You can like stream Minecraft with a paywall.
So, the server itself will be streamed publicly.
Uh, to showcase around.
And then, um...
Um...
The server itself can only be accessed by members.
So, uh, just to let you guys know in advance.
But I'm super, super excited because it's gonna be like an SMP type deal.
Um, with like custom stuff on it.
Anyway, guys!
My brain is super, super fried.
So, I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
Uh...
As always, everyone, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time!
Everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!